hi there Steve Kaufman I want to
continue in a way in the same vein as my
previous video where I talked about you
know the role of the classroom teacher
and I want to have this as an exchange
with language teachers and language
learners and I noticed that a few
teachers did comment on my last video
and I think would be great if we could
really have a discussion and then maybe
in a subsequent video I can refer to
some of these comments certainly some of
the comments that I received in my last
video were along the lines of I tell my
students that the grades don't matter I
tell my students that they need to spend
time with the language they don't do it
you know and in fact I saw an article on
the internet about some new way of
teaching languages that involves the
teacher you know giving them a lecture
on some subject and some kids found it
interesting and other kids were asleep
in the class so yeah there are some real
problems in the classroom not everyone
is going to be motivated but I refer to
this talk as what I call the art of
language learning and and that's what I
want to get some feedback on if we can
establish what the skill is in language
learning that might be helpful and so
that if the teacher can sort of
inculcate at least for those who are
interested this this these the art of
language learning how you go about
language learning and what the key
elements are then that might be helpful
obviously having a good attitude like
being motivated is not an art it's it's
it's a condition for success but it's
not it's not the essence of the art of
language learning spending the time is
also a condition of success and it's
probably dependent on your motivation
but it's also not in this sort of in
that sense the art of language learning
and people always say to me for example
oh well you just have a knack for
language learning and that's undoubtedly
true because I have done it so often if
you do it anything a lot you're going to
get good at it but the implication
almost is that you are born with a skill
for language learning you were born with
some gene for language learning and a
lot of people convinced themselves that
they don't have this gene
some other people do have this gene and
of course I've always said that that
can't be true because if you go to
certain countries like Sweden a lot of
people speak foreign languages very well
I don't believe the Swedes have some
special genetic predisposition for
language learning so you know but they
have some of the other things going for
them like a lot of exposure to the
language but let's move away from the
motivation and the time that we spend
with the language and then let's just
look at what it takes to learn a
language what is this art of language
learning what is this skill that we have
to develop and I think it was down to
this third element of my Trinity you
know motivation time on task and the
third one is noticing it's developing
the ability to notice what's happening
in the language and and that's why I
feel that in teaching in the classroom
if the emphasis were on understanding
and and developing the ability to notice
the language which in a way is it's not
passive but you're not having to produce
the language you just have to notice
what's happening in the language it's I
once called language learning like doing
a jigsaw puzzle so once you have enough
of the pieces in place you can start
speaking but until you have the pieces
in place until you have a sense of the
structure of the language until you have
a sense or at least a significant
vocabulary you can't say very much so
there shouldn't be this emphasis on
producing the language and the correct
correct production of the language we
shouldn't give the kids the extra
learner the expectation that they're
going to learn to speak particularly
quickly because they aren't and even if
they did learn to say a few things it
wouldn't get them very far because
language is two-way communication and if
you can say something and you don't
understand what people are saying to you
then it's not much use so take away the
obligation or the illusion that they're
going to learn to speak quickly and say
your task is to understand the language
and to notice what's happening so one
thing that is for sure is that just as
with the jigsaw puzzle if you were given
three or four or five big pieces to the
jigsaw puzzle some of the smaller pieces
might start to make sense to you but
well you don't have anything in front of
you not even really a picture because
you have no sense of this language all
the little pieces all the grammatical
explanations all the tables of endings
none of these things have any lasting
effect you can study them until your
eyes get tired and they aren't gonna
have much impact and I notice this for
example in Russian you know the endings
for the say even in the nominative
nominative plural you know there's
different e ending some is that funny
ly some is the e I never paid much
attention to it I read all the
explanations soft consonants hard
consonants no lasting impact but when
enough of the other pieces are in place
now you're left with a few little
tidbits tidbits which often seem to be
easy to explain but which which simply
don't stick they don't stick until later
on so the first thing to understand is
that the things that we can notice when
we start are different from the things
that we will notice later on and the
more we have things in place the more we
notice so how can we get students to
notice or how can we train ourselves to
notice well I think if I were teaching a
language I would begin by pointing out
only the most obvious things in a
general way and either reading with the
class or if we had a screen and we could
maybe use different highlighting for
certain aspects of the language for
example it's enough to say that in
French there is gender notice that there
is a la fine
notice that the if you wanted to get to
the point where say to tell them there
is agreement but never with the idea
that they have to remember it and they
have to remember which verb which nouns
are masculine in which you're feminine
they aren't going to remember those
things
similarly in tense saying you know there
are different tenses in Romance
languages in English talk about the
generalities in Japanese they have these
little you know what talk she wah
another little comma after the the you
know subject of a sentence or a not an e
like the wah and the need a indicate the
direction of you know it's sort of like
a preposition that comes
after the Mount all of these things can
be pointed out in a very general way I
say but don't worry about that
I just pointing out a few things and we
want you to read and listen and try to
accumulate words and and get some sense
of what the little story is about that's
the other thing I said in my previous
video that if you see a list or let's
say ten sentences that all contain a
particular pattern that that can help
you notice but that's only true after
you've had a lot of exposure to the
language I realized on on reconsidering
because with you begin with that it's
just too much it doesn't mean anything
you've explained to you that there's a
dative case you kind of vaguely
understand that that happens but but you
have no real feel for it
so you still have to begin with simple
stories so that at least the story
however dumb the story is twenty-second
little story hello how are you what's
your name it has some sense there is
something there that people can can
identify with because they can
understand that the that sort of also
has meaning in my language those is it
this is how they say it in that language
listen to it listen to it say words and
and maybe have it pointed out that there
are some things happening there for
example this language doesn't use
prepositions the case the endings of the
announced change just some very general
general suggestions along those lines
and you know have the the learners focus
initially on the content because they
have to get somehow the big pieces of
the jigsaw puzzle filled out but then
there are things that I noticed that I
do to help me notice when I review my
vocabulary and I have a lot of
vocabulary I don't do it with the
intention that I'll remember them but
I'm always interested in the connections
between words because that helps me
notice because there's lots of words
that sound the same initially and so if
I in link for example I can search by a
root word I can search by prefix or
suffix and so I can see words that
contain some of the same components and
see which ones are connected and which
ones in fact are quite different and I
don't necessarily remember all that but
it helps me notice next time I see that
word because I have spent
time seeing how it was similar to our
different from some other words I kind
of notice it a little bit better even
when we when I work in Lincoln I save
phrases because it's a certain pattern
even the act of saving that phrase helps
me to notice it and then if I tag it as
I often do that will eventually give me
a list of ten or twenty or thirty words
or phrases that contain the same pattern
and then I can review them together and
reviewing them in flashcards or multiple
choice or we don't have dictation all of
these things are just different ways of
going over these words and phrases
watching for patterns and in focusing in
some of these patterns then the next
time you listen to something or you read
something again you'll be just that much
more likely to notice it and if you
develop the ability to notice your
understanding is going to improve at a
later stage when you feel confident
enough to speak of course the speaking
also helps you notice because you notice
where you struggle to find a word but at
the beginning you struggle so much that
it's just overwhelming you can't give
people too much to notice at first you
have to build up a base so that a few
things stick out and those things might
be different
in the first three months second three
months third three months and so forth
so cultivating this ability to notice
and then later on as you're speaking you
may want to record your voice and to
listen to how you sound versus how the
native speaker sounds but again I
wouldn't do that until you're well along
because initially trying to make the
sounds of the new language is simply too
difficult I wouldn't attempt to and I my
experience I don't attempt to pronounce
until I've had a lot of exposure to the
language so I feel that you know if
teachers could somehow reduce the
expectations that either learners make
up themselves or that we make up the
learners in other words the expectation
that they're going to speak they're
going to speak correctly they're going
to be able to apply these grammar rules
I think those are all unrealistic
expectations if the expectation is
you're going to learn to understand the
language you're going to
and get to where you can comfortably
listen and read and and understand more
and more of the language because you're
going to increase your vocabulary and
along the way you are going to take the
initiative and starting to notice the
patterns and as a teacher we can help
you we can spend the day on or a lesson
on a particular pattern pointing out
where it occurs maybe I have it on a
screen with some highlighting pointing
out these patterns pointing out
relationships between words eventually
looking at word lists that the students
have have gleaned from the reading and
listening and identifying some of the
relationships in terms of patterns and
so on and of course focusing then
eventually on specific patterns and then
doing it in different ways that might
involve competition between groups of
students or between individual students
but all in a light-hearted way and with
the understanding that that the any
correction is any sort of wrong answer
is not going to detract from their mark
it's not it's not a black mark against
them it's it's simply a step in the
process of increasing our ability to
notice what's happening in the language
so I kind of rambled a bit and I
probably not have been as clear as I
would like but I believe these
disability cultivating the ability to
notice is at the core of the art of
language learning so that if we put in
the time if we have a positive attitude
and we can notice what's happening we
will eventually learn to speak and I
have I know this is a fact from my
Russian studies most recently where I
spent I would said these two years
without speaking and I haven't spoken
very much last night I was at a dinner
with 20 Russian people here a Russian
language meetup in Vancouver and it was
a little difficult because five
conversations were going you know across
each other and I couldn't hear so
clearly it's not like listening to the
radio where you were you know the person
is just talking to you but I was doing
fine I was quite able to you know carry
on my hold up my end of the conversation
have not having spoken very much at all
so if you devote yourself to
comprehension if you devote yourself to
noticing the brain will
on these patterns the brain will do it
you have to cross the brain but you can
help it along with doing things that
help you notice or conversely the
teacher can help you by helping you to
notice and in that sense again I'm not
in agreement with the extreme crashing
dice to believe you just do a lot of
extensive reading reading content that's
95% you know and consisting of known
words I just think that takes far far
too long and I think there are things
that we can do to help you notice the
language and also to help you to learn
your words faster so I've been on a
ramble a bit of a longer ramble but
mostly I'm interested in getting some
feedback both from learners and teachers
as to whether you know there isn't
something there that we can change the
nature of my teaching and make it more
about cultivating the ability to notice
and encouraging people to notice and
maybe even learners who are not
motivated by the language can be
motivated if there's some kind of a game
in in uncovering and unraveling a
mystery or discovering the language on
their own and finding examples of these
patterns like a treasure hunt in some
texts so and of course it may well be
that I'm totally unrealistic because
I've never taught our language class so
I look forward to all kinds of comments
both positive and negative and I'm sorry
that I dragged down so long thank you
and Merry Christmas if I don't speak to
you soon